next super chat i got could you date an
atheist or someone who doesn't believe
in soul mates or someone who's
completely different set of beliefs from
alex schmidt
um thank you for the donation
okay so i would like to go first on this
one okay because i went to china the
next the last topic i couldn't but me
personally i couldn't at all okay uh
somebody that's the atheist me
my family being born from
[Music]
most my friends from the caribbean i was
born in new york a lot of korean people
of toronto new york london all
throughout the uk
um i've had certain experiences in my
life life and death wise where basically
i'm like yeah god is real
kind of thing and
i just couldn't do it eve even if my
mother father and other people took me
to church and said tries to believe in
god i would
but that being said but the certain
things that i experienced in my life
especially from the pandemic to now
i couldn't do it um so she would have to
be christian
or catholic or whatever
uh more times more time than not more
dude more time than not about
does he only date christian girls
i got a question because you talk to me
beliefs are very important how you're
raised i was raised christian but yeah
what if you fell in love with a girl
let's say she's
buddhist or she's muslim but you love
the girl how do you do that
and in terms of how do you raise your
kids like this is something we talked
about okay my friends like how do you do
that because
i know personally like i've had family
members have cut off relationships
because everything was going good but
just the religion was just so key that
they're like yo i can't raise i can't be
going one way and my husband's this way
yes how do you move doing that knowing
that all right so and the bible says
what you need to be equally yolked
equally yo easily
that being said you said buddhism muslim
well i might give you a little quick
fact that and a lot of people don't read
the bible enough like christians don't
read the bible enough i'll be brutally
honest i started doing it more when i
got um when i came overseas because i
had a lot more time on my hands and i
said i want to grow more as a man
and god said
um a man is the head of the household
but the woman is the neck and the woman
just as important as a man so
this head that we all have
wouldn't be standing without the neck
so i'm gonna let you i'm let everybody
know that now that being said
um
so i i did my research
uh
not necessarily just online but within
the bible and
uh abraham they called the abrahamic
faith judaism christianity in islam
so islam was birthed from ishmael
ishmael
was hagar hagar was the wife was the
concubine of um
of abraham
and for the simple fact that
um sarah abraham's initial wife couldn't
have children she had children right
and when she had her first child ishmael
and
eventually
where are you going with that
islamic different because islam is under
the umbrella of the abrahamic faiths
with judaism and christianity i just
we're talking directly like i just want
to know if you dated christian girls
i forgot what the question was
okay girl girl
essentially is the father of islam under
abraham and jacob his second son
is the father of christianity
even though he's not jesus christ
god in the flesh that being said i feel
like certain um
certain
um i'm all for for in love but for
travis charles personally obviously you
want you want to marry somebody with the
same faith yeah values that you have
yeah reality i think most people look at
that first first and foremost you don't
think god would understand
if you talk
you found you found love you believe in
the buddhism
let's say you're going to heaven
well
you believe in god you're doing
everything you're praying this and that
your wife is something else
quote-unquote you should be going to
heaven no she might not
so would that be a problem then if
you're if we're talking in those terms
did that be a problem the abrahamic
faith
christianity or all religion that's what
i'm saying i'm talking i'm just talking
about you in general you love this woman
to death
she believes in something because she
was raised like that yes and you believe
in something because you're raised like
that yes
how are you gonna feel because you can't
just you gotta just break something just
like that
you can't you don't think god will
understand if god so if god is you know
so forgiving so i understand you don't
think he should would understand that
but this is what i'm saying well if
you're are you christian i'm a christian
but i'm saying like that a pillar of the
christian belief is you can't like get
into heaven unless you're baptized
i believe in jesus christ yeah yeah so
that's
i've been baptized i've been baptized
baptized
still
but
i know you've been but here's the
problem with only dating in your church
okay it's actually not really a problem
for men because there's more men in the
church
but
oh no sorry more women more women more
women sorry sorry there's but for women
they would always say in my church like
back home that like you could only date
a guy in the church but i'm like
there's three girls for every one guy
that's conservative
what yeah yeah so
then all these girls i think just end up
alone because they're waiting for a guy
in the church that's never going to come
so in my opinion the church kind of
keeps women single and i don't think i
think god is conducive to like families
like he wants families to start yes and
i don't know i think there's something
about like biblical institutions
that have been running men out of them
the last like 50 years what do you mean
like like why are all these men they're
men used to be really involved in the
church yes and but they're not anymore
so something about these institutions
are running men out
in europe yes okay one is because men
might be seen as i don't think i can say
this one
you can't say it on youtube it flags it
okay
what
young children
okay yeah involved with the young
children
yeah
yeah and then the second is the rise of
independent women
in the church
honestly what i'm thinking about when we
talk about church institutions is like
one thing person this is just a side
note
i think a lot of people
need to
focus more
on their relationship with god yes then
the church because i had
growing up i had a mother who put all
her time in the church this and that
this and that
and then there will be like shady things
happening in the church is going on
so why are you but at the end of the day
basically it's all about your
relationship with god yes it is so all
the other stuff don't really matter so
when we put all our time
in uh doing this and that for the pastor
for
i don't think i think it's a waste of
time not a waste of time but like you
can put your efforts in better things
well every institution is going to get
corrupted at some point like there's no
there's not a perfect institution
but i think but i think that you got to
ask yourself the question does that mean
we just do away with